good wednesday everyone this week good
day las vegas is conquering the
quarantine
yes ma'am we're showing ways that we've
gotten through the pandemic and maybe
you too
by trying something new of course i
showed you all the
mayo recipe that i've been working on
and alex how about you
yes chef bowtie well yesterday we talked
about how more and more people have been
fostering and adopting pets this past
year
and tomorrow i'll wrap up the series
with a look at how people
have been spending your time organizing
your home
maybe you have maybe you haven't well
sherry i could use some organization
because i haven't necessarily been
trying anything new what i've tried to
do
is to get something we all could use a
lot more of it's just some fresh air
home it's a wonderful place to be
[Music]
but when it's also where you work or
where you teach your children
the piece of home can be a little
claustrophobic
one solution one tonic for the dull days
of pandemic
for me it's getting outside
no foam no congestion all the space you
need
and plenty of pictures
clearly i'm not the only one we are
noticing that quite a big strain has
been put on the
federal land agencies and their trails
almendra johnson is with get outdoors
nevada
she says our trails and parks are more
popular than ever but while it's
tempting to jet straight to red rock
canyon or mount charleston or lake mead
johnson advocates a different way to
stretch our legs that's kind of
the goal too is to get everyone spread
out but also to to not overwhelm our
federal land agencies red rock is super
busy right now
plenty of local parks within the valley
have great trails and views
from sunset park to lone mountain to
mountain lake park
if you need to get out of the house if
you need room to roam
it's not as far away as you think it is
kind of being aware of
of how much space we're taking up while
enjoying it and sharing it and that's
kind of what we're doing
there's a lot of places to get outdoors
so if you want some ideas of places to
hike or stroll there are infinite
resources online we're going to put some
links online a little bit later on this
morning
travel nevada obviously get outdoors
nevada visit there's a bunch of them
online even just like google
best places to hike but the important
thing that elmendra was mentioning was
uh we always think i think of red rock
or mount charleston or lake mead or
valley of fire and those are all
wonderful places but
so many of our parks are big enough that
you can walk around and you can really
enjoy without having to go
so far out and really overwhelm some of
those smaller areas
yeah and you can see a lot of nature i
mean you can go out to wetlands park and
then we just have a lot of
great neighborhood parks nate that have
natural trails and things to see and
discover as well
so uh my son and i were coming back from
an errand at uh jones the 95 and we saw
a sign by the side of the road bonanza
trail that i did not see before so
that's a there are
urban pedestrian hiking trails too john
yeah in fact
right behind where i grew up in green
valley pittman wash is a trail you can
just walk through there as long as
there's no rain or anything like that
and it's
sort of like nature you're in a wash but
it's obviously uh
right through our neighborhood there so
it's important to explore certainly to
get out of the house a lot of us have
been cooped up for a long time
you don't necessarily have to drive all
the way out to you know
death valley or something like that
there are plenty of places that are
close by where you can
stretch your legs especially when it's
so beautiful outside we're blessed with
so much great weather alex you know that
because you're out walking boaty all the
time
i sure am whether it's nice or not and i
also liked uh don't you like seeing how
langler spends his time inside
got the guitar got the hockey
now we know what you do at home he's
walking around with a camera
looking at me